the most common question that we receive
in our extension offices across the
state of wyoming
is what type and how much fertilizer
should i put on my garden and landscapes
it's a question that i particularly hate
because i always like to be right
without a soil test i really can't
answer that question
in this 20-foot raised bed i've already
taken two samples and i'm going to take
a third
and put it in a bucket
i'll then take that bucket
and i'll mix it up
really well
i of course have sampled the top four to
six inches
i want to dry this soil out
wet soil doesn't travel well through the
mail
i'll then take a quart bag
put my sample in it
i don't want any
plant material or
organic material i really just need the
soil
well then put that sample in the mail
and send it off to the lab
if you need any help with soil sampling
techniques or where to send your soil
contact your local extension office
there's a really great scene in the
movie men in black where tommy lee jones
has a little spoon tool and he just
picks up some soil and hits a button and
it tells him everything he wanted to
know about the soil i've always wanted
one of those
but until i can find a store that has
one
the way i get the information that my
soil has
and what my plant needs are is to send
it off to a lab and get that information
back
this is hudson hill university of
wyoming extension you're watching from
the ground up
you